peu plus
[Musique]
et maintenant à vous de jouer le
kaléidoscope est à 12800 francs et notre
nouvelle énigme à 500 francs gérard un
premier candidat c'est monsieur joël
moulin de cours hier dans le hall
d'accueil parce que j'en ai un autre
le premier candidat qui n'était pas
prévu au programme poujoulat et à la
dague et vous n'avez pas vu alors ok
comme maintenant pour se marier parce
que peut-être dans quelques temps de
changer mb oui à tout
non mais ça va venir alors peut-être
comment tous les mamadou sall est
tricoté pour votre wii et où j'avais
fait un cadeau y avoue déjà et chapeauté
côté mathématique mais là il me manque
le cas chez les japonais
mais j'ai compris un homme s'écrie aussi
ça veut dire quoi
am je vois que ses clients japonais et
en anglais parce que voilà on va faire
un petit 4 tous savent eux doit vouloir
dire commanderie côté des chaussons non
ah ouais vas chercher un petit côté des
portes à quoi vous donner le petit cap
tous vous avez le tenir comme ça il va
me sortir encore quelque chose tant que
c'est pas de souris ça va oui il ya vous
apprendre comme il faut que voyez vous
reprenez la pelote de laine
je tenais bien sûr et la pelote de laine
deviennent les femmes qui tricotent
prennent exemple sur vous j'ai
l'impression que jamais elles finiront
de raison qu'on m'avait la télé tout ça
qu'on n'avait pas le temps d'être à côté
c'est pour ça qu'ils vous ont fait de ce
qui a trait au thème est magique et il
faut tricoter comme ça le contraste est
mort à ty s'appellent et la laine mais
comme ça dites moi on a souvent tricoter
pour vous montrez nous comment vous
faites une maille à l'endroit une maille
à l'envers c'est pas la peine
mais ce que wade était coté à l'aide
c'est pour ça que c'est magique parce
que celle dédiée à tricoter
vraiment alors franchement y'a pas à
dire on a touché de matériel on avait
peut-être vos cahiers que la laine et le
dénommé on va montrer tout le monde sait
déjà et a dit oui à rien du tout et de
chimie magic salon politique hôtel pour
votre bébé est allé d'un côté mais de
l'autre
tout ça alors pendant que vous parlez
vous fait de grands gestes pour attirer
notre attention sur un point pendant 5
se passe quelque chose un bon après midi
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
nous avons que du courage bon alors on
était sceptiques
[Musique]